[Music]
the Walt Disney Company filed a lawsuit
against Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
accusing the conservative politician of
a quote targeted campaign of government
retaliation against the media giant
DeSantis has dismissed the lawsuit as
political the days of putting one
company on a pedestal with no
accountability are over in the State of
Florida Ariane Kenpo Flores has been
covering the year-long power struggle
for the journal he explains what you
need to know about Disney vs DeSantis
the dispute between Disney and Governor
DeSantis began over a law that DeSantis
signed last year
called the parental rights and education
law which a critics called the don't say
gay law and it essentially restricted
classroom instruction on issues of
gender identity and sexual orientation
we were opposed to the bill from the
outset but we chose not to take a public
position on it because we thought we
could be more effective working behind
the scenes engaging directly with
lawmakers and after Disney came out
against that law it triggered this
escalating battle between the company
and the governor that culminated in the
governor basically stripping Disney of
its control of a special tax District
that allowed it to self-govern the land
that houses its theme parks and save
tens of millions of dollars the
corporate Kingdom finally came to an end
earlier this year the governor and the
legislature decided that instead of
ending the district they would retain it
but rename it the central Florida
tourism oversight district and remove
the Board of Supervisors that had long
been controlled by Disney instead
authorized the governor to pick the
members of that Board of Supervisors
okay it is in the books right here
[Applause]
Disney had secured a number of
agreements with the previous board that
basically locked in zoning and
infrastructure and and other rights that
would allow it to develop these
properties in the future on April 26th
this new board declared that these
agreements were null and void
Disney picked the fight with this board
we were not looking up for for a fight
Disney sued the governor and the board
members and others in federal court in
Tallahassee
what they said in the lawsuit was that
the governor had basically orchestrated
a campaign of retaliation against the
company for having exercised its Free
Speech rights and so what Disney is
seeking with this lawsuit is for a court
to find that these agreements that
Disney secured are valid Governor
DeSantis has given very little
indication that he's going to back down
on this fight I don't think the suit has
Merit I think it's political and so it
looks like the parties are going to be
locked in litigation for quite some time
what's at stake for DeSantis is the
potential effect of all this on his
presidential aspirations
[Applause]
because widely expected that he will
likely run for president in 2024. the
argument that he has made for a
potential presidential run is that he is
someone who is willing to take on
corporations we will never ever
surrender and that he is someone who
wins policy fights and so that puts an
imperative really on him to emerge
Victorious from this battle